the staff is also welcome to this edition
Our program is special that
about games is that the game
in this edition made in Portuguese I am the
bruno oliveira I work in the team of
blogger here in mountain view
California
I worked in Brazil before and I am
o neto marinho developer advocate
Android stays there in Brazil along with
There you are based in são paulo a case
so there is a warning in this episode today
we are going to give a general introduction
It's about what goal I caught, I felt like talking.
a little crisis from the point of view
technician is for developers and it is
are the airplanes that are available for
the 27 however was some introduction
Overall it's not about the service it's all over
our main source of information
about for everything in the power of attorney is this
site here in what is our documentation
google news service general
just for you to see iraq bigger mr.
in the developer.apple.com bags bar table
this is the site in which you have
time I almost think that almost all our
documentation is there dodo play game
the staff was traveling platform of the
planet and did not see when it launched google
playing games when it was released on
and just remember that some game was
Launched on google mobile, right?
That's when we launched the service.
It's cool and we can do what
likes to give more prominence so pro
people who develop games that
suffering with some things that
we have been keeping for a few days that the
truth where they play suffered with some
things people in the mobile world too
it's not for sure
good to so most games have a
even if it is a game that does not
be competitive he has a certain
competition and implied competitiveness
that for example if you can reach
at such a level only achieved so many
points and then enter sometimes it's cool
you put in the game for example the
creative concept between the concept of a
high-score grade 10 then sometimes make
play the game much more interesting
it's not because I use the player feels
He is playing for something, right?
I'm not playing just to spend my
Time I'm playing to put a
chooses us to respond show my friends
managed to make 6,000 points in that
plaster game
so sometimes it becomes too much game
more interesting and talking about friends
there is one thing too
so I did not have to play alone with her anymore.
true to every comic, right?
It's true then we also have a
a major part I think donated three
games is just the multiplayer part
So we have the whole family.
It's boring for you, that is.
It used to be boring.
keep a server and in c4 people then it is
know if he received a call in the middle.
in the middle of the night claiming to be a server
caught fire and quote is so 1990
The longer a visitor is
super excited by everything is going to fall your
service because you're not waiting
what traffic a thing there because there a
trainee data center stumbled across the river
there it was only jonas
so a very cool part is
right from there the team very read
so this we provide for free
ie you just have to make phone calls
perfectly free you can
to play multiplayer between players
including not only invitation multiplayer
not the player's, it's never just
invite friends also want the
concept of automatic right from the
from which you can for example do
a young player with random people
and maybe you do not even need to meet and
in the circus of each other to
able to play against each other and this
It's very cool, it's about thinking proposal.
so it's google was launched on
google mail only works with android
played for me, that's it, that's it
this is what I would think if you hear
about this service but not really
we run natan android on
this while the oab only then is one of the
great advantages of our service is
just that it is that the four then
you can write your game if you
android web game play if you can
do is integrate the three web platforms
has no multiplayer
android for now this to remember has
some episodes of English were his
mother her episodes that have an accent
I do not go on time the west has tips
2006 Exactly funny you see in
android channel has a video about how
do something for sna
but it's because this service is you
What more is it to listen to your friend and
also unfortunately the
he also does not get can use service
in games it's not exactly you
meet sl players are people
also can not be used for them that the
Another game offers also works
then this site is right here
in your diet then here it is
divided into this part
general in the then if you are nobody
with substance concept ahead 2010
I think for us that we are accustomed
with mystery games no reason is a
something you can force to kill
five enemies find without eating
things is an upcoming event
a cloud server a very cool thing in
What diesel?
This is very cool of course you see is the
next is just one way you
can record the status of the progress of the
user on his google account then by
example the user has already completed the six
first levels your game you play
this can not be useful later when the
player to play on another device in the
he has another to hesitate tempted by
example he will notice is that he will play and
I suddenly know the first six
levels are already a lot
This is really cool because it eliminates
one of the main factors that make me
give up a game that main factor
is the following I do not want to play
the first world type of that game of
new and he may suddenly be in the
him on the subway bus
I think at home now on the board but
o fai potala the level of blocked
I always say that
things is nature is has properties
with cell phones or cell phones and
They tend to fall in the water, do not care.
be exceptional exactly they are
attracted by liquids so it is so
common yes I do not know there gives problems and has
to change the new phone that you do not
can live without and suddenly you stay
without your levels is not this is not a
it is a very bad experience then the
observe the following here we have a
a major difference here sometimes
people ask but google no longer
had a solution for Claudia before already
did not have the drive that was just
to write network state
but it's that difference that people
always say that the difference between a
cheese grater and a chainsaw
if you're trying to overturn a
tree and build a house a roadmap
cheese probably a good choice
it's not impossible but I've already tried
make the river does not use cheese grater
to build houses will vote for
but then but if you're trying
roll the cheese for example, right?
is obviously a player who is already very
better because it does a chore
even though it has less power than the
that a select then certainly is clear
which always has a little less 6 has
less power than google drive sdk
But it works for this.
only for this are these orders made
accurate - you actually record them only
512 are 512k at this time you
play 512k on the net and load it back
that's just it works divided into 16
shops including organizing want to save a
slot slot in phase status slot
we will not send the data as an object
Big memory will send something.
that your game is enough
recapitulate that state he was
at the moment you can send one
cut a phase of something like this
exactly is it you're going to send the form
most economical possible to represent
that state will not send a zip of the
whole game because otherwise it will actually
is that the marché was exactly what it is
That's it, it's not going to work very well.
what else we are entirely
integrated game controller that fully regulates
integrated with google plus then
example you can also use the service
google plus like you
you can do an interactive post by
example the player just finished
that superficial level of your game that
no one has ever gotten it before it can
pick up an office here in your game
may include, for example,
functionality to enter the post that
lets you post something on google
plus with the consent of the user
of course but it can encompass saying
I got through this phase, it's so cool.
that this is not a direct drive to the
your game in place twists another user
that clicking that well does not have
moreover a form of use to the
users to advertise their game is well
cool even though the idea is precisely
that and say 'we world trash
the players are always asking
for us
Ah but how do I do for the player
find out my game in my game is the biggest
history game already started already
witnessed but only that no one is
playing has watched 20 members who
It's the personal matter of my office.
but for this but playing the game because
and you can put the game stayed
deserted, right?
to then in addition to putting the fifa match
there are many more have many more avenues
It's just for you to get this
to discover the feminine beauty is
very new church can not choose
to bring Portuguese even
discover guilt skills at
availability of the game one thing in the
ear that the prisoners - exactly
exactly this is a show about
Portuguese grammar for now
that's just it if you
including putting better multiplayer
still because what happens if I play
a game that is very cool multiplayer
invited grandson and grandson has no game
installed what happens is that the grandson
will see on his cell phone he'll see a
notification saying something is not full
of inviting to the game x is this born
you click on it and you do not have the
game automatically the grandson goes pro play
store where it can download or x then
I'll get one more user there.
just because you've implemented multiplayer and
that's what we're aiming for
discuss game design because so but you
can sport in many ways as per
example asking the user to achieve
more friends as an asset there too you
can drive this installation
the staff is in short order is a very
powerful that if well used can
to invent incredibly users and and in
a virtuous cycle where you have more
usual playing more regulation your ep
your game and more people then install and
better every year 560
exactly then the crisis only has
advantages so far those have to
borges again he borges is that
thing that we as players already
We know
we also have here the leading match of the
more advanced in the then give us here
we have a very important distinction is
between the public and social beneficial leader
it's not a very cool thing
next sometimes that public scrape
sometimes there's always that guy
country that made 29 points and nobody ever
will be able to hit that school because
nobody in the world has so much free time
how to apply the team's motives
motivated campaign so that's why
it is also very important that you have the
social gogh leader he presents
among your friends who is who has
first that is second
although because with country caches
and we invited the largest donation was so
now if you've seen it right there
The cooler you are to see that I am what the
your boss is gone and you say no
has no reason in this universe for
What's your boss gotta have a singles on?
bigger in that game then you obviously
does what all the people I would do that
you spend the whole next day
playing the drug
I liked your boss's choice is good
then we have that session of
multiplayer at the then
here explains everything about how
do one means a lot of medicine
make the blood in make you will invite
friends do that thing that was
talking that it's d
I take chinatel you find
people are automatically coming
play now to the details
again you see you come
then the documentation here is has the
people have the part of cetep also want
explain exactly how to do
configure your game and this does not
went into detail but this is just one
process a cake recipe will follow
step by step you set up your game
then if you put your exile in the
your android app you can start
to use p
then has the specific documentation of the
android so far have documentation
detailed here how to make enem as
put the leather belt exactly I
I told you stay, so it means it's also
It was really easy for you to start using
this today is not
so it has no ipi reference has the
west part also on the internet about
absolutely nothing then this
Greek friend session for me, that who?
need to keep repeating has videos already done
in English
the staff asks in the comments there the
We have a project to make more books.
In Portuguese, nobody looks at
involves only dealing with bruno that is
a disaster
We've also taken some videos
byte at the team's debut soon
can also have a video game on stayed in
connected there is also a web then
we do not forget the web and when
said I do not mean only web is like this
is not sobral read is a pickup sub
so you can call know from
Anything I can do
call robes if you want
implement a game that can play in the
your fridge
it is clear that in a game with those who
I signed up on March 25 th there
very little can invent because sometimes
can do embedded hardware
just like that is everything
sde decision with the platform to use
your weapons without any limitation
some things are reminding
android platform does not launch
web platforms is multiple especially
only have android on air will have logo
soon he is working on the projects
which has for now can have the social part
to sell active board which is already a good
seek on your stern game good part
decode sure then comes the
part of the world 60 is worth giving a
look at the whole site again the rb7
developer.apple.com baguim you just
there is everything there now another one I think
what is important is our website
ceps and android
not that the echoes of the other platforms
are not important but like me and grandson
job
android is highly always pulls the
Sergeant looks much less the shapes
exactly a master is exactly then
these are the android servants we also
we have time for other platforms and
has saline link on the documentation site
huh
we talked about android the question here
It's the one on this site here that you can
find android time that is a
site in the state that is not only here
you can download the large ones as well as
if you find any bug
setrans can send a patch to
To correct it anyway is the people, right?
joão vi the staff is with all the
benefits already thought if you have an exam
detailed here about what the
that we have people time between
For example, they have a very
exciting flame button click 2000
soon you can compete with your friends
and see who gets more often a button and 20
seconds
Then yes for Christ, then I
modernization of the game is what to do with
that today I'm cool exactly where
we believe this goes from
redefine the concept of fun in the
21st century
Then there's another guy, it's about
certain cloud server has instructions
detailed information on how you
including commands at inn including
how to set up an absurdity only you
to see the power of collaboration and
community who submitted the bild
program in biofuels was one of the
community collaborator was not the
people made the bild they sent the people
put here because it works the other
other important seven here in
url this is the goal from the last point with the
bpp but I got on the phone
This is where we have our
call it so bring it if you are
which click on niches
the editing is our tracking process
you'll find a bug on the platform in the
the front bank neighborhood in the large in a
blog in the 21st century but the oxy can
correct directly but does not ask better
although the will but here are the
I'm dancing on the platform.
calling to those pillars that returns
to 7th is returning 76
So what's the problem, you two?
place here in Iceland before a
personal search make the cake suddenly already
with whom you have reported this bug you can
including the status of when
will quit whether it was submitted not if you
found a blog
of toulon play so the dollar climb
about this can he have submitted
a lot of collaboration from you exactly
that the other is another very
important here is the following we have and
What happens if you have a question
every game I'm starting with games I
I'm lost in the middle and I do
exactly then for this the best place
to ask your questions and you are not
who revealed it in the only dishonor
Confessed, we have a tag now.
specific for the goal I got myself then
Are you guiding your question with this?
tag some member I do not know that our
staff here will probably see you at
very small period and if people
know how to respond he will respond in the
so stood out and it was this one this is
the list of all questions that do not
we pay with playing games and remembering
if it is android also can not win
with android there is also the
android also to end up seeing it there
play is that potential answer more
fast and yet clear of the whole
community is watching that there you
can use a player in the future who has
the same doubt that you were doing well is very
good power with collaboration and exact
is for example our list of
questions they are not clear and sun
about the blow and then obviously the tags
are not exclusive so if you have to see
with the other game and android then you
can pay with android and gol took me
make it as attractive as you can
to see people interact enough
I'm not even in the
people interact enough with the community
answering question if she is very
well inclusive good reputation blows
now let's determine one
demonstration is this here is a is a game
is to see that we wrote here just to
demonstrate how it works I'll increase
the volume here it sounds pretty retro
so it's a game in which you have to
draw on things you have to take
in these little green things are aliens
who are mauro you are protecting a
lighthouse then you have to shoot us
virus that you can not take the packets
of data that are the squares to 2
This game is played live not if you
you are interested in playing the address here
bdco brings the code pointed to spot.com
then you can play the
will as long as you do not go take it
high score is not going to be forced to
stay the next day interpretation is
a lie, I actually was
I already leave the leader board of this
because there are people with stories
absurdly great to leave then if you
go here and want to play, you can play
here is just the game, right?
the note is a super retro thing does not have
that kill these animals in the effects
by george lucas
if you can get a body
if you can get there but you can
make a combo of 12 he is
destroys
so I'm going to stop being there until then
they start the headlamp direction
this is good if you take advantage of a
Data package
now has also got a debut of course
because not even a complete game will be
Then I'll have be here and you
need to figure out how to do it and then
notes
every game has to have a good game and
now this loss again with stories the
fantastic and scores the year
then note that here for example has a
recreational activity on the list of
all the assets I got in that
list goes on the web what is interesting
next in android in the west we have
interfaces beauty in the system you can
will make a method call you only
can display a giant screen in the
time we do not have because normally
the experience of the game she and a friend in the
straw to use with it exactly here
For example, God wants to see the same is
super easy because you carry the
cruise borges has a codec you
again on your web is to be able to make a
console yourself in rivers behind may
play and went to make a console to do
An example robot games will receive other
conditions to use platforms you want
here is a list of blows, right?
including also live and had the duty
cool to see you're fantastic
so from here it's just that
social part and not only my friends and
right-hand side is just the public leader in the
So you can usually see that I
I'm on the list my friends are me
I am here on the public leader list
under 8,600 I'm well below that
No, I have to work hard.
The front is what I think is good
here is the difference button and if not
work then you can do
alone through here but I'm already
leaving so you do not have to do anything here
and I think that's more or less what the
People had to talk today, I think the
The idea is precisely not to make a
personal presentation on google
playgames I do not have an order here
Thank you very much Brazil for
help them with this presentation I think
the staff will now enjoy having a
notion of what he can do with google
playing games and then I was at ease and
destroy with your ideas
exactly then is this here with the leader
continent, especially with
returns and note you can give a
much better difference for your people.
user of your game there
It's good that the team could be difficult.
implement in the game no more cloud
server whatever works is super easy is just
put it just put type one line of
code in the right places and you know
so hard you can just have
all this additional engagement with the
is that you could not do without
That's it, then, I guess.
message if an agent in the plus is
a detailed look here in our
documentation so remembered here the site is
only vote for the main site
I want her down here, she got with
belly barbarian services and has it all
Thank you so much, I'm a grandson there.
I'm bruno oliveira until next time.
next